white's rook too strong and the pawns
are running yeah
and there's no way that black's past
porn there on the left can
even think about advancing and artemiev
putting in a very powerful performance
he just overwhelming hikaru's defenses
yeah but it's good that hikaru keeps
playing i was about to say he looks
calmer than he ever did
previously in this game but um he just
needs to play himself into some kind of
rhythm
just get some moves on the board he
knows he's going to lose this one anyway
is he being distracted by something
because he keeps turning around
and being quite angry maybe there's some
noise maybe there's some
disturbance outside his window some
building works going on
okay yeah i'll tell you i'm just keeping
things simple offering a bishop trade
white is material up why not take things
off the board
remove all of your opponent's defensive
pieces and
that pawns stepping forward again next
move white's just gonna give a check
he's gonna lift his rook up and that
black king is almost trapped already and
there we go check that black king has to
step back
checkmate is coming white's pawn is
running he definitely is looking at
something he carries
and he gives up wow first blitz game is
over artemyev with the white pieces he
won